a
una votación que muchos ven como el
camino hacia mejores prácticas laborales
más de 6000 empleados de general motors
en la ciudad mexicana de silao votaron
el martes y miércoles para elegir a un
nuevo sindicato tras la disolución de la
unión patronal que los representó
durante 25 años pero si yo tengo 26 años
y con el mismo sueldo no no no se ve que
presida ya de 26 seguimos para acá ya
deberíamos de ganar como mucho lo que
después criticados por su posición
generalmente patrona lista los
sindicatos mexicanos han tenido alta
influencia política por décadas una
historia que podría cambiar bajo los
términos del tema que un acuerdo
comercial entre eeuu canadá y méxico
vigente desde 2021 que obligó a este
último país a mejorar drásticamente las
condiciones laborales es la primera vez
realmente que se han utilizado
los mecanismos de la de la nueva ley
federal de trabajo que se reformó en los
2019 y también en los mecanismos del
tema para obligar a un sindicato de la
a retirarse de la planta un
sindicato que los trabajadores nunca
pidieron de los cuatro sindicatos en
disputa el que conquiste la mayoría de
votos podrá negociar un nuevo contrato
colectivo con la empresa que se
comprometió a respetar los resultados y
a brindar el ambiente para una elección
libre y justa aunque sus empleados
esperan que esas promesas también
incluyan una mejor distribución de las
ganancias que en 2021 superaron los 10
mil millones de dólares